across the slot couldn't come up with it
maoy sizzles a pass to grizzli and a save
by markson of Chillington makoy one timer
and Mark sucks it up Noah Hanan in his walk
here hubero over to kco hubo a save by the
falling Swan Center gets a real good look at
San on that little tow drag took that one off
the mask by the looks of it checked by grizzl
zaka to the corner off makoy skate hubero a sa
by S Tim Thomas style was trying to get to the
front of the net maybe made some contact
po defle off the skate Bruins who trying
to make a nice possession play it's openo
head man's the puck for kzo and Anderson's
shot is snagged by San off zary's stick are
a first round choice of the flames in 2020
and Carlo is going to go for holding yeah
tough [__] for Brandon Carlo sizzles It
Wide through the slot Sher go former devil who
came over in the tley trade Co has a gift and
Marksman markstrom Cav Kazo
scores well no way to make you beloved by
your new teammate Under Pressure along the
wall moer makes the save a good glove
stop on Chie Coyle and then in quick
transition Calgary's talented guys on the
power play kzo zaka good check on Blake
Coleman zaka takes on three Flames van
re Dyke in wrestling match with zaka
forward stands his ground Jacob peler a save by
Swan steam can't get it past zeri turns
in the corner wear along the Blue Line
Anderson gives it back wear throws it on
San Bist skates it out through Center Hing a
shot tan of a rebound and backin almost Cashes
in Hanahan along the line Hanahan a shot and
swan makes his save off high you get a little bit
more physically involved and that'll allow you to
pick up the pace of your game walker door right
on swing Rond coil three Bruins around the puck
and it dies on the bind three on two up ice codre
to Zer and he scores odd man rush off a Bruins
chance you really don't have anybody in position
to help the defense handle this outnumbered Rush
and it's a Well executed play grizzl gives
it back poock Saka gains the line mamoo's
backand Shillington scrapes it in Swan to
forward it's G's pass Kevin Roney saved by
San protects the puck weager a r shot turned
aside by Swan makeo steps in Blood and blocked
by Co of this game yeah that pu H by Brandon
Carlo and allowed kco to come in off that right
wingy wco stopped and and rebound rolls back
to markstrom and re Dyke to PO blocked by rer
15 seconds to go poso gets his first shot
on goal concentrated effort to play below
the goal line we saw a lot of this in that
17 game streak where they put pressure on
the opponents by forcing them to play deep
in their own good back check by grizzli Coy
to mat grizzli sends Mamoo ahead and dents the
post back quality chances nice little backand
feed from Coy that's the defenseman coming
late they keep it on side attack with speed
pick your spot glove side beats moxom
inside of the post to coil poock fires
off the end boards zaka the puck retrieval
zaka off hand stick and the Bruins have one
back and they become interchangeable they
don't get locked in a one spot in a five
on three you get a little motion you put
people in different spots with different
looks but with a shot mentality you'll get
good results zaka on the one Tim yeah they
get a decent deflection off hand stick I believe
and you can see what marom is overplaying on that
side shat Kirk Maran shovels to De Brusque
tanov rushes with hubero grizli gets underneath
hubero cadri sandwich hubero
scores Calgary regains its two goal lead
one gift after another to spoil your power
play opportunity and kill your momentum and
then a gift of a turnover and hubo shows you
why he's got a ton of skill ruin can win a
puck battle along the wall squirts free hubo
quickly spins into a shooting position gets it
off quick Far Side over the glove of Sway and
get back down to by two shag Cur flatters
it to co backlin off the outside of the
post Hanan steps past brusk closes
and a backand and a goal by Noah
hin the second power play goal of the night
for Calgary nobody exempt tonight when you
talk about the Bruins in down 4-1 you obviously
need a save here hand if in a gifted skater he's
just going to power to the outside made Bert's
okay giving up that shot you know you're not
allowing him to get to a scoring area what you
don't believe is a scoring area well the fans
have the answer vocally hining misses wide at the
final siren the final score Calgary 4 Boston one